Michael Thomas how are you my friend I'm
doing great how are you good I
appreciate you taking a minute or two I
wanted to ask you first about the
Ezekiel Elliott hearing ongoing today
what will happen in this hearing with
Harold Henderson will evidence be
submitted or will it just be a review of
the facts and the ruling no one really
knows at this point Tom the way appeals
typically work in a court of law there's
a standard that applies to the ruling
that initially was made and there are
different standards that apply under the
justice system you can do it all over
again from scratch mm-hmm you can apply
various levels of deference arbitrary
and capricious is a term of art in the
legal system and that's the standard
that the league office previous
previously told me applies here and if
that's the case there should be no new
evidence the record gets sealed you only
consider the evidence that was already
introduced and you make a decision as to
whether or not the suspension imposed by
the commissioner goes beyond the basic
bounds of fairness and reasonableness in
light of precedent etc but with with the
reports that we've seen and the
indications we've gotten it feels like
Elliott's going to have a chance to go
in and introduce new evidence although
that really shouldn't matter at this
point and also here on Henderson
reportedly looking for some type of
contrition from Elliott in order to get
him to reduce the suspension that really
has no place in an appeal process either
and it all adds to the confusion and the
perception and I hate to use the term
kangaroo court mm but if you look up the
definition that's kind of what it is and
you were through that a couple of years
ago with Tom Brady it's all it seems an
effort in advancing the league's broader
pr interests creating the impression the
league is taking these matters seriously
and erring on the side of punishing
player in lieu of failing to punish a
player and specifically not punishing
him enough because when that happened
that's when the pitchforks and torches
come out and that's when the
commissioner has to worry about his job
so this is all PR driven it feels like
it's made up as they go along and it
doesn't have the safeguards that you
would think a player would would enjoy
before being branded a domestic abuser
it's the same thing really when you
about the introduction of evidence and
an ongoing effort to determine what the
facts of the case are as the process
continues is the exact same thing that
happened with Tom Brady the destruction
allure alleged destruction of a phone
that happened well after the timeline
indicating that Brady destroyed the
phone at a particular time that was
introduced during the appeal the Tom
Brady's appeal so that was what's your a
pin there Tom let me tell you this is
where this is a great example of how
typical legal standards and typical
legal processes simply don't apply here
because in any other setting if that
evidence had come available during an
appeal hearing what would have happened
is it would have sparked a completely
separate investigation a completely
separate process as to whether or not
Tom Brady failed to properly cooperate
with the investigation it has no
relevance to the deflategate ruling that
previously was made you go back to
square one on that one you go forward on
the suspension for being involved or
having general awareness or whatever the
final language was on the deflation of
the footballs but that just shows you
that there really isn't you know the NFL
likes to set up its own in-house justice
system there really isn't a clear
parallel to the actual justice system so
much of it is made up on the fly make it
up as you go the ends justify the means
and it doesn't hold up to scrutiny when
you try to be objective about how the
NFL goes about reaching these decisions
in article 46 basically in essence
states that sorry but we can do whatever
we want that's the article in the
collective bargaining agreement that
says the Commissioner can act in the
best interests of the game basically so
and that's been there for decades Tom
and here's the thing you know Gene
Upshaw and his predecessors agreed to
that
and I don't think anybody ever expected
that the league would abuse it the way
that arguably the league has abused it
in recent years but it almost feels like
the league is pushing this power as far
as it possibly can to compel the Union
at some point to say okay uncle we will
give you something we will play 17
regular-season games we will expand the
playoffs we will do something just
please let's have
a fair and appropriate in-house system
for giving our players justice when they
find themselves caught up in the years
of these processes the problem is will
you ever get to a point where all
players would make a concession that
protects maybe one or two guys every
year I think it's interesting to see how
far Roger Goodell has separated himself
from this process because Lisa Friel the
director of Investigations who not
ironically came aboard after the Ray
Rice investigation was such a disaster
she was brought aboard to make sure that
these investigations were handled
differently then she presided over the
just the one game suspension for Josh
Brown now in turn a year later you have
a six game suspension for Ezekiel
Elliott on what by any standard is at
least conflicting evidence as to what
the accuser and Elliott can consider
their relationship to have been they
keep credibility is key here credibility
of Elliott credibility of Tiffany
Thompson and Roger Goodell made the
decision without ever sitting across the
table from Ezekiel Elliott or Tiffany
Thompson and looking them in the eyes
and distressing on his own whether or
not he believes what they're saying and
now in this appeal hearing Tiffany
Thompson won't be there Harold Henderson
will be executing this appeal process
without ever having scrutinized her the
he refused to require the NSO to make
her available and he also refused to
require the NFL to give Elliott the
notes and the transcripts that were
generated from those interviews how in
the world can you and if he's guilty he
should have been arrested he should have
been charged he should face the
consequences but everyone is entitled to
some basic ability to prove their
innocence how in the world can Ezekiel
Elliott even begin to prove his
innocence when his lawyers can't
question the accuser when they can't
even get the note so they can parse
through them and try to find some
inconsistency but they can point to and
say look there's a flaw here this
undermines the entire outcome it really
that's why I was very reluctant to use
kangaroo court but that conclusion when
you look at everything is inescapable
you talk about outcomes - and and what
outcomes will be impacted as a season
goes along the team will be impacted a
business and industry will be impacted
schemes for Ezekiel Elliott that can
impact the industry that'll impact the
owner that'll impact that franchise five
games were handed down similarly to
vantes perfect
similarly in that it seemed a little
capricious to give him five games what
are your feelings on the vantes Burfict
suspension because at some point these
owners singularly are going to have
these disciplines handed down to key
players and say you're hurting my
business with what are capricious
decisions and suspensions when you're
taking key guys up there are differences
here though one and we're so conditioned
tom to think that the NFL has complete
power over every matter of player
discipline this is one area where the
NFL doesn't yeah.but hearing an officer
who was jointly hired and jointly paid
by the league in the Union it's either
James Patrick Derrick Brooks in this
case it's James thrash he handles the
appeal his word is final and it's it is
a true form of Independence and we've
seen these suspensions get overturned
and as a release Devon says perfect the
fact that he has a history has
influenced the five game suspension it's
progressive discipline like you would
see in any educational environment any
workplace you start small and if the
behavior continues you increase the
punishment if the behavior continues you
increase it Birkett got suspended three
games for an illegal hit on Antonio
Brown in the 2015 postseason so now it's
five games if this was an illegal hit
and there's two factors here there's
been a lot of talk about the new twist
on the defenseless receiver rule that
applies while the receiver is running
the pass route I'm not so sure that I
see contact to the head or neck area on
that replay but also this notion that
was unnecessary I talked to our river on
the new senior VP of officiating just
within the last hour
he said that unnecessary element because
the ball was out and perfect could see
the ball was out that's part of this to
his history comes into play
James trash will decided and he may end
up missing the first five games but
could see and did see a different things
and that's what's hard for a person who
is watching through video did you see it
well I know I didn't one quick last
question as all this goes on Mike I have
to ask you is there a point at which
these singular owners whether it be
Jerry Jones Mike Brown Robert Kraft we
can have these individuals who are so
irritated
the league's decisions that it causes a
schism among ownership that really leads
to some chaos at that level which in
course will visit itself in the week
itself well I don't think it was a
surprise that as this Ezekiel Elliott
controversy was bubbling up the news
emerged commissioner was close to
getting an extension I know back in
March Jerry Jones argued that all owners
should be involved in negotiating the
commissioners abstention he believes at
a certain level that they pay too much
and this is an easy way for him to
attack back if he's not happy with how
this is handled now there was a
six-person committee I think that was a
report from Sports Business Journal a
six-person Committee of owners that is
negotiating this contract but you know
that there's a connection a loose
connection there between Roger Goodell
compensation and this growing concern
you know because as this this unblinking
eye at 3:45 Park Ave and it just kind of
rose across the countryside it can be
any team you know I said this time and
again is it related to the Patriots when
fans of other Kings said why do you care
you believe the Patriots are getting
railroad it's like we're your team could
be next
that's why you should care even though
it's the Cowboys now with the Patriots
before it was the Saints five years ago
this is sense of just randomness where
one team finds itself caught up in this
in this mess where the procedures don't
feel fair process seems driven by the
results that the league desires that's
not good for anybody and I'd like to
think at some point owners are going to
grow weary of this problem maybe it's
going to take every team to get dinged
by this before they all can realize this
process needs to change alright Mike
Florio Pro Football Talk thank you so
much for taking the time Michael and we
will be back you know you always you
always admit a swear word when you're on
my show and I really thought about doing
it to you but since it's danced her I
decided not to
I've already been spoken to twice on
break about it okay here okay good only
imagine all right Mike see ya the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience